how's it going everybody welcome to the
show hey like us talking about random
nonsense now were gonna talk about some
serious stuff because apparently New
York has decided that they're just gonna
suspend the First Amendment and and this
is the craziest story I can't believe
it's real
yeah free oh man I almost don't believe
it I can't believe it's real
yeah I guess nobody fights for the
Constitution in this country it's Swiss
cheese man it's been Swiss cheese for a
long time yeah sixties it's been just
like it's a tattered rag at this point
and I'm not saying that this to
disrespect the Constitution I love the
thing yeah but no one's gonna do
anything you know what I mean like the
de Blasio is gonna be like for your
safety there is no First Amendment yeah
the problem is is not everyone who's
upset is gonna go out and protest
no one will it's gonna be I'm sure
there's gonna be people that protest but
those people will be arrested and
whatever beaten up sure it's gonna
happen oh did you watch the movie the
patriot no Mel Gibson no no your watch
yesterday I just watched that the other
day yeah I don't know why oh you know it
was this is crazy man Oh tell me it was
the number one trending movie on Netflix
was it really yeah why why I know I know
what's preparing for those that don't
know the patriot is about the
Revolutionary War
mmmn like the British are really really
bad yeah it's a great movie I love that
movie Oh movie mm yeah yeah yeah 20
years and it was it was so I turned I
opened up Netflix and the Patriot with
Mel Gibson is the top one for those I
don't know it is about a man who says no
to the revolution it's it's so well
written Mel Gibson was great in this
movie he's like they're having a
convention in South Carolina and they're
gonna vote on whether or not to join the
war effort with the other colonies oka
and he he he stands up and says tell me
why should I trade one tyrant 3,000
miles away for 3,000 tyrants one mile
away a legislative body can oppress
someone's rights same as a king yeah and
then they're like you know everyone like
yo and then the the you know commander
captain guy goes I took you to be a
patriot and then he goes he's like well
if you're asking if I think the colonies
should be independent my answer is they
can and they should but if you're asking
would I go to war with England the
answer is most certainly No
and then when they all when they all
decide that they're gonna vote for it he
goes mark my words this war will not be
fought on the frontier but in your yard
you know in you in your gardens and your
homes and your towns and it was like
it's powerful stuff yeah but the point
is this dude did not want to go to war
and it was only when the bad guy shows
up and I'm not gonna spoil the movie
it's 20 years old but the bad guy shows
on an old and basically messes with his
family because he's like the snide
British guy apparently the British got
really mad about this
oh really made the movie they're like
how dare you show us to be such monsters
because the bad guy like he kills kids
oh it's like it's a British lieutenant
or something and he's like a child
shoots the kid or whatever yikes and so
like the British Beverly met but anyway
this dude just wanted mind his own
business and then because of this he's
forced to join the revolution and so
it's like the whole movie takes place
and kind of like a side arc you know
it's not Washington or anything it's not
like good yeah it's just like one dude
and he's like a guerrilla tactics guy if
I cool Cherokee tomahawk how did I not
watch this movie haven't seen it dude it
sounds off and it's just like seeing
people run they've like the Gadsden flag
don't tread on me and like he made a
flag and he's running uh and he's yeah
it's great and they make the the British
look like like morons
oh really yeah yeah it's awesome I mean
it's basically like they're they're
farmers they're militiamen mm-hmm and
they're underestimated and they use
guerrilla tactics to like surprise these
are like hoity-toity anyway the reason I
bring this up is New York has just
suspended the the First Amendment the
whole state or the Senate can't believe
it the city and YPD commissioner no
protests allowed that's insane what's
crazy about it is that just the other
day the Patriots the number one man that
looks like what are people thinking
about yeah the resolution and now
they're cutting you off from protesting
man this is crazy stuff out so anyway
that was like a long little opening but
if you like to show hit the like button
you can jump into super chat you know
what I was thinking if you are gonna
super chat because we usually go about
an hour before we actually get to them
just make sure that when you when you
post a super chat include like the
context to the best of your abilities so
you know often we'll see someone super
chat something like no way that could
ever happen that would be nuts and I'm
like I don't know what that was in
reference to
there yeah but I mean it's all it's up
to you you'd super tell me whatever you
want you want a super chat something
about your cat stealing your wallet or
something I don't know or ferrets do
that ferrets steal your Slocombe
use the cat in here yes but boku just
came in and said hello to me hello
everybody
you want to introduce the cat oh yeah we
should where is he he's coming to you
now he's cute I don't know if you guys
have ever met boku meet the kitty he's
the best this is get him oh he's out oh
there's a cat oh great he's like what am
i doing you guys didn't tell me I was
gonna be on the show so he's straight
chillin he's a table ornament now
alright yeah yeah what were you talking
about so uh cats his name is actually
bucko buuut boku and he was named for
Jordan Peterson he's hunting on the
table I think he found my water but no
one calls him that anymore
we call him buku he's now trying to get
my water I wish you guys could see this
oh that is pretty cute I just shoved his
face in a mason jar
someone said soy cat nope he is a
carnivore and eats meat nice try oh he
got it and he yeah he's drinking your
water
well that's no longer your water Tim
that is the cats water so anyway we're
supposed to be talking about the end of
the world and no it's not the end of the
world it's just New York nya - the Bill
of Rights sorry that sort of feels like
you took your man that's what it is I'm
sorry I had to say it man they don't
there's this annoys me though they don't
they don't care like they don't care
clearly but what do you do what do you
do I guess here's what I think might
happen there'll be a bunch of lawsuits
after the fact yeah a scary thing though
is some some New York judge being like
well it was an emergency and you know
emergencies don't really count we can
take your rights man yet all these all
these other states are now opening up
like California's now finally prepping
to open up Texas is opening up it's like
all these these different states are
like yeah we can probably open up and
whatever is slowly moving towards that
they're like we're gonna slowly open
these things man you are you guys are
both really distracted listen my water
man he is drinking you guys need to see
this is rather cute but man I wish I
could turn a camera I'm sorry guys it's
okay look I have water because we're
doing ishani to drink it
boku is is quite spoiled
now he drank too much he can't reach it
anymore knock she's really jamming his
face in that job oh there he goes
careful I don't want his head to get
stuck in there no it's like only his
face he'll be fine it happened before
what really yes with that same same kind
of jar in our room yeah so careful yeah
so anyway you guys can't actually see
what's going on right now but there's a
cat drinking Tim's water and they're
infatuated with it it is quite oh yeah
you listen you you had to stop taking a
photo to change so I was thinking that
some of these cases might end up going
to the Supreme Court though because
there's no way that the New York Police
Department can put this nonsense on hold
no and expect that to not go to Supreme
Court 100 precisely so okay let's
they're basically taking a poop on the
Constitution is that better I already
did well I mean we get one right no no
no oh no not that one
not that one no wait oh man I just I
don't think it matters to a live frame
to be honest okay but it just means that
when we put up the clips we have to go
in and like bleep them or something good
thing she's doing yeah YouTube is
basically TV at this point and and like
yeah if it's really about the
advertisers because YouTube they'll
basically suppress the video oh right
okay so it's like look man you have a
choice do you want to swear or do you
want to you know get money well talk
about get money it's about like actually
have your video oh yeah well by symbol
yeah yeah cuz like even if you're
subscribed to this channel something for
some some people will point out like it
doesn't even appear on my channel like
they've gone to my channel before and
been like there's no video yeah that's
weird yeah man happen to me I mean I'm
I'm a moderator here and I can you know
whatever but it still didn't show me the
video every time it's like yeah what's
going on
what what what people don't get about
how censorship works is that it's not so
people like to say things like Tim self
censors it's like dude if I don't say
swears yeah I'm on man you know all that
I did I did I did it the other day about
the the Democrats saying that they don't
care Joe Biden
you know abuse that woman right and I
straight up saying the video like I know
for a fact this video will be D
monetized D ranked and it was half the
viewership what a surprise yeah
No exactly so no I'm gonna talk about
whatever story well here's what people
don't get about how censorship works
when it comes to like biased media
they're not forcing any of these
journalists to say things okay it's peer
pressure right but but more than that
they hire the people who already say the
things they want that's true so when it
comes to YouTube I'm not ignoring
stories right I just don't talk about
those particular things so you'll see
some people might want to talk about
certain conspiracies whatever and
they'll get eliminated because that's
the thing they talk about YouTube is not
forcing people necessarily like
obviously I can't say the word Voldemort
but I did make two videos with the guy
and then YouTube end up taking them down
hmm
yeah so you know there are some hard
limits but for the most part I cover
exactly what I what I want to talk about
like there's no but I'm pretty sure my
time will come you know they'll come and
they'll hack the channel a half mm-hmm
yeah because it's really funny the
longest time when it came to the
censorship debate and free speech and
all that the argument we heard from many
on the left was like but my private
company
oh but YouTube's a private company right
what about now yeah let's pull this up
de Blasio NYPD Commissioner no protests
allowed in New York City such a bold
statement you can't do that yeah yeah
apparently you can because not nothing's
gonna happen no one's gonna protest
that's it
that's against federal law like what but
it's not it's not statutory law it's the
Constitution so the Constitution says
they will make no law establishment
establishing you know religion speech
press whatever so that's technically
that's not a law then technically
speaking so what they're doing right now
constitutional it's a it's a violation
of civil rights right do you think the
ACLU will come out on this one I'm
better I don't I don't know I don't know
if I believe it I don't think so
nope because the the argument right now
about whether we should reopen or not is
tribal and it's true leftists and
Democrats who are like we mustn't to
reopen the AC so here's what happen with
the ACLU I used to be a very proud fan
of the ACLU okay and I had donated to
them I'd actually worked at a
fundraising company where we raised
money for them what's that stand for
again the American Civil Liberties Union
Oh God they're anything but oh really
they were they are famed
for defending the rights of the Klan
marching in Skokie Illinois they
defended unite the right in Charles
ville mm-hmm but something interesting
happened my gran twins lived in Skokie
things started getting really polarized
you know over the past ten years and
they started to build up a base of
hyper-partisan individuals who clearly
have no principles yeah so there was a
poll that came out recently from YouGov
showing that when it came to Brett
Kavanaugh Democrats polled said 70% said
that if if you could prove the
allegations against Cavanaugh he should
not be allowed on the Supreme Court they
asked the exact same question about Joe
Biden and only 30% agreed that he
shouldn't be qualified for president
that's ridiculous because it's not about
principle it's just lying to get power
no and we're seeing it straight on you
so the ACLU Donald Donald Trump comes
out and he says you know early on
Trump's quote was something like Donald
Trump as a statement written it said
Donald Trump is calling for the complete
and total shutdown of Muslims and in the
country something like that and then
later on he instituted this this travel
ban which included you know North Korea
Venezuela not just Muslim countries and
the leftist media and Democrats ran with
the narrative Muslim travel ban even
though it didn't ban most Muslim
countries you know and in the countries
that weren't Muslim whatever okay but
the ACLU immediately stepped up saying
you can't do that it's unconstitutional
and so all of a sudden they saw a
massive spike in donors and boy did they
love it yeah I'm sure so when it came to
Charlottesville and unite the right the
ACLU started losing tons of subscribers
their donors were just bailing out
saying fu you know we didn't thought you
were better than this and so the ACLU
had to backpedal and just completely get
rid of their principles so now gross
yeah they don't actually support
principles anymore the ACLU and and much
like many organizations it's really
funny there's an organization called
Free Press and kind of what do you think
they do get paid to do stuff so their
nonprofit called Free Press sure what do
you think they're their core advocacy is
I don't know free press yeah freedom of
speech freedom of speech freedom of the
press defending your you know right to
publish and they launched a campaign to
get Alex Jones banned from Facebook
because they opposed Free Press that's
really they don't know thwarts Free
Press mean thanks for checking out this
clip from the Tim cast IRL podcast we do
the show live Monday through Friday at 8
p.m. if you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or check us out on
iTunes and Spotify and we will soon have
this podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you